but I didn't do that I did that like I'm
wish all right I'm gonna stop we do that
in CrossFit we do this yeah I know I
have to you do CrossFit I do I try I try
I try it's late sure Sangeeta Patel from
UT Canada dude watching this boat I'm
scared of water so this was very fearful
and on top of sure drink I know I drink
water but being in waters but we are
finally sorry no it's the shot you're
afraid I'm right it's the line it's the
water brownie brownie
my biggest fear I'll swim okay I I can't
but I have such a fear that I don't get
in the water where I can't are you from
uh Toronto I know I know I know so that
was a big fear for me watching this but
it was such a brilliant film had so much
fun doing it as the director was this
film everything you wanted to be never
they're always horrible how did you say
it was a huge a lot of fun yeah
Jason was more than okay Jason talk
about his movie he's adorable sweet
funny
okay compensate he really sitting in I
know it's we're about a film but you
know when I went through with my top 10
choices yes and they weren't available
there was oh is it no it it's fun to be
friends with Jason not that we're
friends I wouldn't presume because he's
just fun and you know that if you get in
the bar fight he's gonna kick someone's
ass I was thinking he was talking before
about being in the water and doing so
much acting in the water yeah yes you
want someone who can do it
you want someone who looks good doing it
like he knows what he's doing and that's
this guy he's done a lot of stuff but
he'll then go and do more and practice
and get better at it he does the work
for the director yeah that's what makes
you such a brilliant actor I understand
that you're in Fiji well don't get crazy
brilliant this a little much I think
you're brilliant that's good
keep swimming I mean he makes my
brilliant you know and what is he but
you were in Fiji that must have been a
brilliant experience for you yeah it was
phenomenal I'd never forget it as I live
it's just to get down and you know
literally inches away from these bull
sharks yeah two and a half meters 3
meters in length really big sharks if
you're not used to I mean we I've seen
sharks on a recreational dive but to
actually put yourself behind a coral
Boulder and be literally inches away
from these things that are feeding on
these sort of tuna heads is it's just
amazing to see you calm the whole time
yeah I was a bag of nerves on the boat
above the surface because you just don't
know what you again into and then when
you're down there it's just a total
different thing you're ready just
everything becomes tranquil relaxed and
you don't want to do anything stupid and
you all of a sudden you're just you're
just fascinated by the whole situation
this way I'm not remarkable you'll never
go will you no I'm just curious Ruby so
looks like water now it's not those
things that you anticipate something and
then the reality is something else so
you people go I go diving with a show
I'll never get in a cage most people
that do things that they don't want to
do come back and go is the greatest
thing I've ever done in my life
and I think that's one of the big blocks
that we have as as humans is all I would
I can't jump off a cliff I can't do this
yet when they do it they liberated and
they go wow what was I why was I so
restricted in my in my thought about
what I want to do yeah yeah so yeah I
would guarantee they can you take me
with you nah come with the XO we go okay
and Pippen stole the show I'm sorry I
chase in love you but close it is a mate
you put a thousand people in the water
and the audience just doesn't care you
put one freaking dog into the shark's
mouth
everyone gets crazy I love you guys
thank you so much
see that okay I did a cool day